We had a beautiful display at the market each
week.
Pretty soon we had a lot more than we could
eat.
And we said 'gosh we got to do something with
this.'
So we really thought we had it made.
Anita and Jim McHaney are retirees who moved
from Houston to the Texas countryside in 2013.
Their plan was to live well and grow food
on a 10 acre homestead
earning extra money selling produce at the
local farmer's market.
We did amazingly well in the early stages.
They grew beets, okra, carrots, kale and Swiss
chard.
Soil out there is very sandy and the beets
just grew like mad.
Now the obvious thing to do, when you got
more beets than you can sell
is to make pickled beets and can them.
Like most states, however, Texas has a so-called
Cottage Food Law
that exempts certain items sold at farmer's
markets
from the state's commercial food manufacturing
regulations.
Foods like bread, produce, nuts, jams, popcorn
and, of course, pickles.
But, what constitutes a pickle?
And who gets to decide?
The McHaney's discovered that the Texas department
of state health services takes the narrow view.
What are pickles?
Pickles are made from cucumbers that have
been preserved in vinegar, brine or a similar solution.
Only pickled cucumbers are allowed under the
Cottage Food Law.
Legislators didn't say that, the health department
did.
All other pickled vegetables are prohibited.
So, in order to sell their pickled beets at
the farmer's market
the McHaneys needed a commercial food manufacturer's license,
to build a commercial kitchen,
to submit the recipes to a government contractor at Texas A&M university
and to register for a $700 food manufacturing
class.
And it's only once a year, so if you miss
it this October
then it's a whole year before you get another shot at it.
We got right down to signing up for the class,
I was gonna take it despite people said 'you
won't learn a damn thing in there.'
And then saw that $700 dollars and said 'you
know, this is crazy, this is insanity.'
Preposterous.
The McHaney's neighbor Virginia Cox, also
grows and sells food at the local farmer's market.
She'd like to be able to pickle her leftover
okra.
I could make a whole lot more on it pickled
because if it doesn't sell this week, I can
take it back to the market next week.
If it's fresh and it doesn't sell this week,
it's not gonna sell next week.
Today the McHaney's farm lies fallow.
But they have decided to take the state of
Texas to court
with the help of the Dallas law firm Drinker,
Biddle and Reath who took on the case pro bono.
Their argument is that the regulations on
cottage food production are unreasonable
and stifle their economic opportunities.
People can't afford that kind of stuff, that
shuts them out.
As precedent, the McHaney's case invokes the
landmark 20015 decision by justice Don Willett
striking down occupational licensing for Texas
eyebrow threaders.
Their challenging the Health Department's
definition of pickles and subsequent regulation
on the grounds that it impinges on their constitutionally
protected right to earn an honest living.
The Texas Department of State Health Services
wouldn't comment on the pending lawsuit.
But defended the agency's rule as reflecting
the most common interpretation of the word 'pickle.'
It forces you if you want to do a pickled
beet
to go to a 700 dollar class that actually
nothing to do with home canning.
And now we've got hundreds and hundreds of
occupations
that you gotta pay the government to do your job.
For now the case is still pending and it's
just entered the discovery phase.
But the McHaneys are optimistic about it's
outcome.
You know we talk about pickling beets, but
it's a lot lot bigger issue.
It's about economic freedom and government
by bureaucrat regulations that got nothing,
well it's who bought and payed for the bureaucrat.